now we all know the only person who is
just as important as the emmy nominees
is the mc of the show so let's look back
at some of our favorite emmy award show
hosts and their most memorable moments
take a look
the emmy awards have tried hosts from
all across the entertainment isles
actors singers comedians even a
screenwriter was the very first host of
the emmy awards in 1949
and soon followed by some early
television stars including lucille ball
and desi arnaz ed sullivan fred astaire
and frank sinatra in 1975 cbs went with
no maine hosts but rather ten mistresses
of ceremonies johnny carson holds the
record for most emmys hosted at four
while ellen degeneres joey bishop john
forsythes danny thomas and jimmy kimmel
each have hosted three times
in recent years late night hosts and snl
alums like andy sandberg stephen colbert
and jimmy fallon have traded off hosting
duties
fallon opened the emmy ceremony with a
brilliant epic song and dance number in
2010
featuring tina fey jon ham the cast of
glee and betty white has been called the
greatest opening to the emmys ever
and this year there's a new funny man up
for the gig
cedric the entertainer has been making
us laugh for over 30 years you've seen
him in barbershop johnson family
vacation the steve harvey show and most
currently on the hit show the
neighborhood on cbs
and he already has hosting experience
under his belt including a season of who
wants to be a millionaire we bet this
king of comedy is ready to hold court at
the emmys
please welcome this year's 73rd annual
emmy awards host
cedric the
[Applause]
what's up
that's you you this
is this is beautiful
well
you have great jewelry too you like you
you're really doing it drew you got like
great jewelry on and see guys we don't
really get to dress like really nice
jewels i'm skipping right to what are
you gonna do what are you gonna wear
what do you think i i mean you know it
is it's one of those things where you
think you can get away with just the
black tux and the classic you know gable
look you know with the hose and the
smoldering eyes i've been working on
that my eyes motor
that's all you think you want to do
right but now
fashion is going a lot forward so you
know i'm actually going to change a few
times
i'm going to come out with some i love
that yeah i love that cedric give them
what they want exactly give it to them
i'm giving them magnum
it works now i love
that you get the call to host what
happens what takes place what's the
circumstances and what goes through your
mind i was like you know i was out
pitching another show so and they were
like getting you like you got a call
from this very important person and i
was like oh
ho ho ho
this is the one he was like hey uh you
know the thing you try to sell us that's
a no but um
but would you want to host the emmys i
was like
hell yeah
so i was excited so that was good it was
one of these
it was a bad call didn't turn into a
good call all in one call i think the
emmys is one of my favorite shows
because i think it's
really representative of the collective
of the way we're really watching
um and yes i i call this the television
this is the prom for us this is our
night for people who work in television
and do this as poor living cedric i know
you're going to be the greatest host
because i've never heard someone say
this is our prom
yeah
it's a coolness that happens in
hollywood on on on those nights when
everybody's kind of dressed up and you
know it's this coolness where we all
kind of like
yeah loosen up enjoy the moments yeah no
let's let's turn it let's do the other
thing let's i want to be shirts off
jackets let's
yeah we're going to turn up old school
also
your good friend anthony anderson is
nominated for lead actor and a comedy
series are you so happy for him him you
know and this is probably i think
anthony's eighth nomination
and so he's never won one so with me
being the host
i'm like bro you leaving out of there
with something i don't know what it's
gonna be
i'm just gonna get somebody's in me for
you know lighting or something and be
like here you go here you go dog take
that
well no you're already on a juggernaut
show for cbs the neighborhood
going into season four
i mean how does that feel i mean it's
very exciting one i don't take it for
granted i've been doing this a long time
and blessing to be in television a long
time and so we're just really blessed to
have the opportunity to come back and
just to be able to make people laugh to
come into their homes on monday nights
on cbs monday nights eight o'clock guys
uh
that's right
shameless plug thank you cedric the
entertainer be sure to catch the fourth
season of his show the neighborhood on
september 20th on cbs also streaming on
paramount black and tune in to see him
host
the 73rd emmy awards september 19th on
cbs
[Music]
you